bonjour je présente alors ouais fait
relever l universitaire romands ser et
chanteuse je vais vous parler un peu de
mon expérience
donc j'ai démarré ma vie comme un cactus
j'ai démarré ma vie scolaire par un
échec que j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
encaisser et que j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
donc à digérer a dépassé et que j'ai
vécue comme un véritable drame
je n'ai pas été prise au concours de 6e
année primaire
ce fameux ce fameux concours que passer
les enfants donc vers l'âge de 11 ans et
pour passer donc de l'école primaire au
lycée j'étais pourtant la première non
seulement de ma classe mais de mon école
je pense avoir simplement oublié de
noter mon identifiant sur chacune des
copies des examens ce qui expliquerait
ce peut-être ce résultat complètement
inattendu donc j'ai toujours détesté les
chiffres concernant l'identifiant j'ai
toujours été un peu impulsive et pressé
heureusement ça s'arrange un peu avec
l'âge je parle de l'empressement et de
l'impulsivité
pour ce qui est des chiffres ça
s'arrange pas du tout donc je suis
atteinte d'une dyscalculie chronique
rare pour une stack sienne et donc à
cause d'un instituteur qui nous asséner
des coups de bâton parce qu'on se
trompait dans les tables de
multiplication en disant fièrement avec
boulemane yourte c'est jade oil valp
donc des coûts pour ceux qui se trouvent
dans les tables de multiplication aval
comme vous le savez étant à la fois donc
l'action de multiplier et celle de taper
malheureuse polysémie donc un autre
mauvais souvenirs surtout que j'avais
souvent des engelures sur les doigts qui
se mettaient à ces à saigner les
mathématiques continue de symboliser
pour moi cette souffrance enfantine face
aux châtiments donc toujours mauvaise
calculatrice au tournant à cet échec
donc au concours du de passage au lycée
imaginez ce que pouvaient ressentir la
petite fille de 11 12 ans première de sa
classe
obligé de refaire son année dans la même
école sur les mêmes bancs
les mêmes instituteur alors que ses amis
avaient un niveau qu'ils avaient un
niveau moins bon pour la plupart étaient
déjà partis de l'autre côté chez les
grands sentiments de honte de colère de
frustration d'injustice un lourd fardeau
que je traînerais de longues années plus
tard
l'année d'après j'ai été admise avec un
17 de moyenne
donc une belle revanche à l'époque ou
1,17 valait vraiment quelque chose c'est
pas à notre époque au lycée j'ai
retrouvé mes anciens amis
kim avait devancé d'un an jean
rattraperait d'ailleurs une bonne partie
vous savez ce que je faisais quand je
les croisais dans la cour je me cachais
derrière les nouveaux ou alors je
faisais semblant de ne pas les
reconnaître et je les fais jusqu'à la
fac
vous imaginez ne pas se connaître
reconnaître mes anciens amis
donc pour vous dire à quel point c'est
traumatisant dans ce même lycée j'ai
fait partie d'une et classes pilotes une
deuxième revanche il fallait que je m'en
sorte avant en dépit de la défaillance
en mathématiques et en sciences
physiques et vous savez à cause de qui
et de quoi donc il fallait que je reste
dans cette même classe pilote jusqu'à
l'orientation qui n'arrivait qu'en canon
avant le bac
ceux qui n'avaient pas niveau était
exclue illico donc mon niveau en langues
heureusement essentiellement m'a sauvé
la chance avait commencé à me sourire en
mettant sur mon chemin une femme est
enseignante extraordinaire saillie dati
c'est ainsi que je l'appelais et c'est
ainsi que je l'appelle encore
aujourd'hui puisque je la garde dans ma
vie et je la garderais jusqu'au dernier
jusqu'au dernier jour
donc comme konami extraordinaire aussi
comme maman spirituel grâce à elle je
suis tombée amoureuse de la langue arabe
mais bien que je parle pas en arabe
aujourd'hui en particulier de la
littérature et et de la littérature je
voulais dire plus largement elle nous a
fait connaître et aimer des robes les
romans de gip ans
enfin l'outil taïmouraz racines etc et
nous exhorter entretenir un journal
intime
une écriture qui inspirera peut-être
inconsciemment mais deux romans en
langue française publié récemment
mais ces deux romans ne représente pas
mes premiers écrits fictionnel puisque
vers l'âge de 15 16 ans j'ai écrit mon
premier roman un roman en langue arabe
inspiré de la vie de mon père
qui lui même écrivait des fictions
jamais publiées et qui continue
aujourd'hui à entretenir son journal
intime
depuis des décennies bien bien avant mon
arrivée au monde c'est de lui que j'ai
dû hériter les gènes responsables de
l'imagination et de l'écriture
j'ai réussi donc à rester dans cette
classe jusqu'à l'orientation
j'étais une parmi quatre élèves à
m'orienter vers un bac lettres réservées
généralement aux moins doués
alors que dans ma classe pilote j'ai
toujours été classés entre 20e et 40e
vous savez à cause de quoi à partir de
l'orientation littéraire je suis devenue
la première au pire la deuxième on se
disputait même pour s'asseoir à côté de
moi le jour des épreuves de
mathématiques alors que je savais que je
suis nul donc dans mon cas être première
n'est pas un n'est pas exceptionnelle
dans mon cas c'était vraiment très
important puisqu'il s'agissait encore
d'une revanche je passe mon bac
le deuxième concours de ma vie imaginez
la peur bleue d'échouer une deuxième
fois il en allait de ma dignité
je le remporte avec une belle mention
pour une littéraire c'est génial vient
la deuxième orientation un choix crucial
la langue arabe était mon premier amour
mais j'avais envie d'autre chose partir
la france me fascine et je faisais
partie de la génération d'antenne 2 que
noter les capter parallèlement aux
romances et arabe j'ai commencé à
découvrir les écrivains français
certains enseignants et sont pour
quelque chose c'est ainsi que j'ai opté
pour une maîtrise en langues et lettres
françaises partir en france pour un 3ème
cycle était devenu mon but ultime
toutefois mes parents n'avaient pas les
moyens de me payer des études à
l'étranger il me fallait absolument une
bourse d'état une bourse que jure j'ai
réussi à décrocher l'année de ma
maîtrise encore une revanche
à 24 ans je débarque en france des rêves
plein les valises
quatre ans plus tard je suis docteur ès
lettres je soutiens ma thèse en un temps
record toujours la peur au ventre je
réussis avec la meilleure des mentions
encore une revanche
parallèlement à ce parcours académique
la musique a toujours été là pour
m'aider à surmonter mes peurs à dire
l'indicible à vivre simplement à
respirer un équilibre sont musique est
impossible au lycée j'ai été active au
sein du club
de musique puis dans le cadre du
groupement régional de musique lycéenne
ensuite estudiantine l'année mon bac je
prenais mes leçons d'histoire et de
géographie en les chantant la mémoire
musicale étant chez moi la plus forte
je les fais donc plus tard aussi avec
les cours de civilisation et d'histoire
littéraire
imaginez ce que ça donne un cours sur la
révolution française
chanter sur l'air de sylt europe par
exemple donc kalfon en france j'ai
d'abord chanté avec un groupe
d'étudiants tunisiens des grandes écoles
je m'en suis là c'est au bout d'un
moment puis des rencontres et des
spectacles m'a permis de m'ouvrir sur
d'autres genres musicaux essentiellement
le jazz en attendant de trouver un vrai
boulot à la hauteur de mon diplôme un
boulot qui ne viendra jamais je conçois
mon premier projet musical je rencontre
un pianiste franco libanais à l'occasion
d'un spectacle auquel il participe
je lui propose une collaboration et l'
aventure démarre peu de temps après des
reprises de fairuz rhapsody ou turquoise
était le titre de mon premier spectacle
en duo sur la scène de l'institut du
monde arabe de paris
n'est ce pas une revanche de plus que de
chanter sur cette scène
[Musique]
google
le groupe
et pour aider
et y
[Musique]
pour
oh
[Musique]
seul
weepu
aux etats unis ont finalement craqué
lavaud
vous
à manille
auj
où
d'après vous
hulu de torigni
[Musique]
mais série
tu peux lire
[Musique]
mais comme la vie n'est pas faite que de
réussites ses preuves de changer la voix
comme la vie n'est pas faite que de
réussite viendra une période aussi ardue
que déterminante avec ce doctorat
fraîchement obtenu
je pensais que trouver un travail dans
ma spécialité allait être simple en bon
jour un travail en france j'étais rendu
à cette réalité le jour même de ma
soutenance que ça n'allait pas être
aussi simple
mon directeur de recherche m'a demandé
juste après la soutenance mademoiselle
maintenant qu'allez vous faire
j'ai répondu sur deux mois j'aimerais
enseigner à la fac il n'a regardé avec
une expression que j'ai mis longtemps à
comprendre ici vous devez postuler à
attendre en moyenne 8 à 10 ans ont avant
que le métier arrive ça avait l'effet
d'un seau d'eau glacée sur la tête
bouillonnante
j'avais deux options passer un concours
afin d'accéder à un poste universitaire
en tunisie ou bien rester en france
désormais 100 bourses de recherche et
cherchent un travail qui ne viendra
probablement pas un vrai déchirement la
tunisie me manquer mais il retourne et
s'était retourné à d'anciennes hantise
retrouver le poids de la société
renoncer à certaines libertés
quand j'y passais des vacances je me
dise du je me sentais en exil en exil
dans mon propre pays
seuls ceux qui ont vécu cette expérience
pourrait me comprendre la france était
également un exil que j'avais
délibérément choisi j'avais quand même
réussi à trouver un certain équilibre un
équilibre précaire mais un équilibre
quand même les trois ans et demi qui
suivront seront mes années de bohème
au bout d'un moment je me lasse de
l'animation dans les centres de loisirs
parce qu'il fallait bien vivre
je démissionne toujours aucune réponse
positive des d'octo des rectorats pardon
je commence une nouvelle aventure
musicale avec un nouveau pianiste un
jazzman français cette fois ci je pousse
plus loin l'expérience du métissage déjà
entreprise avec mon premier spectacle
mon nouveau duo présente un projet que
j'intitule orientale jazz standard est
articulé autour de standards américaine
de jazz mais aussi de standards de la
chanson française
interprétée en langue arabe je traduirai
écrit ou écrit moi-même les textes
chantés
il vous suffit d'aller sur ma chaîne
youtube pour m'écouter chanter
interpréter nardis karvan my funny
valentine ou avec le temps ne me quitte
pas
mater le rallye gigogne trahir ribéry
il semble que oui les richesses
o'leary dory saliba zilina la poule
[Musique]
suite
l'acte et leurs familles
tu vois il
[Musique]
mais reid il est plus logique
huit mois et il convient pour couler la
dignité
[Musique]
il
bush mardi
[Musique]
dès mardi
mettez la à lui
[Musique]
s'enchaînent alors dans les différents
clubs de jazz parisiens mais également
dans les festivals reconnus comme le
rhino jazz festival le crest jazz vocal
l'estival boittin montre autre festival
de la médina aussi parallèlement je
commence la rédaction de mon premier
roman le jasmin noir qui ne sera achevé
qu'en 2008 et ne sera publiée qu'en 2016
tout ceci n'étant toujours pas suffisant
pour vivre j'entends matériellement je
me lance dans un an et dans une autre
aventure dans le domaine
cinématographique cette fois ci je
chante je vocalises pour le générique
d'un film franco tunisiens accompagnés
d'un grand jazzman français on me confie
également la tâche de la transcription
et de la traduction du sous titrage de
ce même film et d'autres films viendront
par la suite et surtout j'assure le
coaching d'un acteur franco kabyle
paix à son âme parce qu'il est parti en
l'aidant à apprendre son texte en
dialecte tunisien 8 qui n'avait jamais
prononcé un mot d'arabe et sacrée
expérience toujours pas recruté je
décide de passer un concours pour
décrocher un poste au sein de
l'enseignement supérieur en tunisie un
creux plus grand dans mon cv aurait été
fatale et puis la vie de bohème ne peut
pas convenir
toute la vie à partir d'un certain âge
on a envie d'une certaine stabilité
je réussis mon concours encore une
revanche certainement toujours la même
peur au ventre je sais pas si c'était la
peur de réussir automne pas réussir fin
de l'aventuré parisienne retour ont
initié de retour une dépression est
inévitable le pays a changé j'ai changé
rien n'est plus pareil
l'écriture est là pour me sauver je
termine la dernière partie du jasmin
noir dont le dans l'urgence du dir puis
je le range dans un tiroir trop intime
pour être publiés par en tunisie en tout
cas je reprends parallèlement les
aventures du champ à déclin des jazzmen
les plus reconnus en tunisie au bout de
presque deux ans nous préparant une
dizaine de titres ces mélodies ses
arrangements et mes paroles et ma voix
le projet n'aboutit pas déçu je laisse
tomber la musique et me concentre sur
d'autres aspects de ma vie ma carrière
universitaire
ma famille et ma vie de citoyen après
l'éclatement de la révolution tunisienne
nous pouvons pas tenir longtemps sans
création je commence la rédaction de mon
deuxième roman une suite indépendante du
premier le tango de la déesse des dunes
jusque là j'ai écrit pour moi et
quelques proches reprendre l'écriture
m'a donné envie d'avoir un lectorat plus
large
je décide de déterrer mon premier roman
de le publier en tunisie il servirait
plus ici abordé les sujets dont je parle
dans le jasmin noir ici est une forme de
résistance face aux dangers concours
notre pays en mutation
le livre est publié dès sa sortie il est
récompensé par un prix prestigieux
il est salué par les lecteurs et les
critiques l'espace d'une revanche de
plus sa réussite me motive pour terminer
la rédaction de sa suite paru exactement
un an après son aîné et la musique
je n'ai quasiment jamais arrêté dans le
faire puisque j'ai toujours écrit en
chantant et chanter en écrivant la
musique étant l'essence même de la
création littéraire
par ailleurs après avoir suspendu les
activités musicales
une rencontre relance la machine je fais
la connaissance de mon troisième
partenaire musical un pianiste classique
tunisien cette fois ci nous concevons le
spectacle métissage mais plus loin
tissage nous sommes nous ne sont
produits sur la scène de nedjma star
hala et en marge du festival de carthage
l'an dernier bientôt le franc
l'ouverture de la première session du
festival de la francophonie de sousse et
il ya aussi l'octobre musical à de sfax
à vendre j'ai eu la chance d'avoir osé
expérimenté ce qu'ils étaient amants
pouvoir d'expérimenter chanter écrire et
même enseigne et ne sont pas des
casquettes différentes
il s'agit pour moi de la même
performance motivés par la même rage la
même ténacité la même passion seule la
passion et la furie sont capables
d'ouvrir les portes de l'impossible loin
de tout calcul raisonnée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
souhila year to do you do sul où tous
les futurs ou les joues fourni
[Musique]
damman oignons
denis
dieu
réduits
et vous
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]